[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever
you want he threw me out at this time
i
all right so nick's new here and now
sorry guys we we prepped him this time
because the last
off the record we uh i didn't prep him
so he didn't know what to do with the uh
whatever we
uh whatever we want to be so [ __ ] up
though i know
what happened wait i'm dead wait anthony
threw me off let's test it wait you know
what nick don't be too hard on yourself
because i don't even know when it
evolved
to the point where everyone in the room
participates in see i
i thought it was just like a cup like
the main guys i didn't think it was like
we're all men guys here yeah thanks man
three times i said watermelon like i was
like watermelon we want
i love watermelon what
your side eye is [ __ ] hilarious like
keep up
but yeah dude this one looks like the
championship lakers right here
kr smith baby that's what you look like
take your shirt off let's see it what no
not yet i'm not ready
does he wear those glasses too i'm
i like to be naked on my own don't tell
me to take it off yeah
are you are you trying to get chiseled
right now is there a good dude i've been
trying to get chiseled for the last
eight years bro
oh [ __ ] i don't know sorry uh no i never
wear shoes
i don't like shoes it makes me feel hot
you know what's weird
okay so um i think seven years ago or
whatever on jk news i would when we
always talked about like
do you like hot or cold better right i'd
be like yeah man
i'm with the hot team because like i
love hot weather
and cold weather i just want to run away
from
but then i did the wim hof cold training
technique and the breathing techniques
and i did the cold showers and i did the
cold pools and all that [ __ ]
and now i actually like the cold
and i hate the hot see i know what you
mean
cause he's always been team cold and
then so like when whenever we had the ac
blasting i'll be like come on bart man
it's it's too [ __ ] you were your only
other voice in this room because me and
gio would be
[ __ ] freezing well bart of david
always was hot right
and plus me and joe we outside of this
office when we do shows we travel
together all the time so it's like it's
always like i'm on the cold side he's on
the hot side
so like let's see if i get into the
hotel first he comes in he immediately
goes
what the [ __ ] about as cold as [ __ ] or
if he goes into the hotel i'm like god
damn joe's hot as [ __ ]
get separate rooms we started doing
after we made more money yeah yeah
because
we wanted to save money so we just all
packed into one little bed but we even
slept at some students houses before
yeah early days those are the good days
like the dorms and whatnot
yeah the dorms but he said like houses
like dorms houses
it's more private than the dogs when
casey went with us to australia and
malaysia it was us three in a room it
was like
bed bed like that right next to each
other yep so you guys push them all
together right
yeah i think casey was in the middle
really i don't know i don't know
sometimes casey would just fall asleep
on a chair editing
like we would i remember we would go to
vegas and i'm like casey man you're a
workaholic
and he's like i'm gonna edit because he
gets super excited about the new project
that we're working on and then when i
look over he's like this
so excited and he would literally wake
up
and then start working and finishing it
dude that's the best time to work though
when you when you first wake up that
have so much energy i'm like oh yeah
so you can go to sleep where you work
and just wake up like yeah
that's a part of this process no because
like in the mornings too there was like
a period of time where he did this thing
where like
we'd be sleeping and like all cuddling
whatever and he wakes up and he goes
this is how he wakes up i'm like what
the [ __ ]
he's like a dog dude just like like i'll
be startled every morning when i wake up
and i'm like you have to stop doing this
i'm going to get a heart attack you
might be like me
i think so it's very similar to how you
explain your thought process because um
sometimes i'm like
i feel so comfortable and if i like take
my time to get out of bed i'll never get
out of bed so it's like [ __ ] you energy
on the floor i actually got more i
actually got my brain scanned by that
place called uh things called brainwaves
or something i should do that yeah but
it's that neuroscientist from ucla right
so i got my brain scanned and then from
so there's like um
you know how you have like like ocd adhd
like you have all these other like
things that people are dealing with i
got a
ddd yeah now you could get diagnosed
from like a um
from like a clinical point of view and
then what he does because he's a
researcher he diagnoses you from a
research point of view like
like uh like with these brain activities
chances are you are experiencing this so
it kind of confirms like some of the
things that i got diagnosed with as a
kid
but when he scanned my brain and sees my
brain activity he's like oh you're a
high cortisol person in the morning
and everyone has high cortisol during
different times of day
and usually the people that are the most
productive are the ones that
have been able to capitalize on it so
for example if you're a high quality
debilitates me bro yes if you're a high
cortisol person
at night and then and then like let's
say you get all your work done at night
and you're able to have like a night
shift type job
you're probably really productive yeah
and so for me i'm a gt-11
shift at the hospital 3 p.m and 11 p.m
was like my
so that's like your best time to work so
for me i'm a high cortisol in the
morning
so he was like he was just like kind of
like a palm ready or just ask me a
question i bet you work out in the
morning huh i'm like yeah you'll do this
in the morning i'm like yeah and so i
think for you
you might even be a high cortisol person
where like if you wake up in the morning
and you don't unleash the beast
and like start hammering [ __ ] away you
might actually feel grumpy
and like oh yeah i get depressed i get
depressed because that's how you by
lunchtime if i don't feel
like productive in any sort of way and
it could be like supe stupid super
stupid like
watering the plants you know the fact
that water plants in the morning i'm
like
[ __ ] i got that's how you yeah and then
i'm so the opposite that i like to like
sleep in
and like cuddle and just be like oh it's
a slow start to the morning like oh
let's like
ease into it and then so like i'll like
force him to do that sometimes with me
and then by the afternoon he's like
ah i was still not productive blah blah
blah
you know you could help me out there bob
we could do something very productive in
bed too
release that cortisol he's talking sex
people [ __ ] sex you know i'm more of
a night
sex person so you got with the wrong
girl so you do both you do
you do half and half we compromise by
doing both lunchtime double time
yeah just start in the morning bust at
night there's a morning sex
you're a night sex me that dude i know
because think about think
think about how motivated he's gonna be
with a boner all day he just had
half the sex in the morning he's oh he's
edging all day
yeah and then at night releases just
letting you guys know it's about noon
right now so if you guys need to
compromise well that way bart has the
bed set up in the back because
what are you doing that's riley's my
cortisol
[Laughter]
but then the opposite happens too like
when i try to have like a productive ass
morning or like meet him in like early
in the morning and i'm just like
don't talk to me until my [ __ ] coffee
like i can't even
function because that's that's just not
you like you might be a high cortisol
like
um you might be similar to me where i
realize that
um i can force myself and like i can
produce that same thing that you guys
have if
i have something shocking so like if i
jump in the pool and it's cold if i have
a cold shower
if i start the it has to be cardio i
realize like
i have to run and wake up that way
or it doesn't start with lifting i don't
know why i think it's the rest in
between i'm just
i'm still not awake after my lift
session i think that's why i like cardio
and then what i realized is the uh for
me to get to this
point of functional like peak
uh it's not right when i wake up i have
to manufacture that gradual rise
and then this is this is what's crazy is
i noticed this when i was mountain
biking right because like
my mind's not firing and it's still half
asleep and i'm going downhill
and it's not stimulating that's scary
yeah and i and
i'm and there's something else going on
here that we should be discussing
we just see joe slamming into trees and
[ __ ] he goes not stimulating yeah that's
why i crack [ __ ]
that's why i crash so like my mind is
not
awoken to the like it's not it's not
alert alert right like when i used to
train with you in the morning i used to
get [ __ ] frustrated because i'm like
getting hit left and right and i'm like
why am i not uh reacting away
and then i'm just it's not firing in an
after
session that was my warm-up and then i'm
ready to go work out for another time
and
another time and i'm like okay so it
took me so long to recognize
that um i have to manufacture that and
wake up but once i'm
up man i can i have endurance to stay at
a high peak
for a very very long time so i have very
high uh i guess
stamina stamina but it's like an old car
that needs to warm up
and then i can go for the long run so
then
that's why i was like man you guys sleep
so early you guys i don't understand why
it's like it took me a long time to get
to that point but i can go on and maybe
pull an all-nighter with that same
type of uh high functional long-range
tesla
i think so dude that's probably why i
gravitated more toward uh endurance
sports and you guys don't like cardio
yeah
my i'm a tesla with a small battery but
there's a lot like explosive short burst
cyber chuck
cyber trump got lots of power in the
beginning and then i just need to rest
after
now cheetah yes they call those one
minute
but like for that one you're just having
them that's true that's right
oh really you're in heaven nick yeah
it's a good minute it's a good time
but you know and um once i get there
though my calm down is also
long so to me it's like if we have a
bell curve right maybe your guys
energy spike is like a it's more like a
high
one it goes extremely high and then yeah
you drop down and you can come down to
baseline faster
where for me it's like a gradual up but
it's also a gradual down
and today's video is brought to you by
feels what i also
realized is that using and integrating
things like cbd
and all that stuff it can help me get to
a point of like
let's say adrenaline right i would say
that is when you're in the zone
when you're at this peak of high
functional you're doing
you're super hyped up like you're at a
rave right and then you're you're
creative you're doing all kinds of stuff
but then the come down i don't know what
people do but for me i do
uh cbd oil and things like that with
meditation to get me to a point where i
can relax again
and then go to sleep so if you're
wondering what feels is it's a premium
cbd delivered directly
to your doorstep what does fields do
feels naturally helps reduce stress
anxiety pain and sleeplessness and if
you only last one minute doesn't really
help you with that i've tried it many
times
a few drops of fuels under your tongue
and feel the difference within minutes
the thing to remember about cbd is that
finding your right dose
is very important so leave room to
experiment over the course of a week or
so you may need to take more or less to
get the effects that you're after
there's real human support behind it so
are you new to cbd
fields offers a free cbd hotline to help
guide your
personal experience fuels works
naturally to help you feel better
there's no high hangover or
addiction uh join the fields communities
get fields delivered to your door every
month
you save money on every order and you
can pause or cancel anytime
fields has me feeling my best every day
and it can help you to become a member
today by going to feels.com
off the record and you'll get 50 off
your first order which is a crazy deal
with free shipping that's f e a l s dot
com slash
off director become a member and get
fifty percent off automatically taking
off your first order with
free shipping fields.com off the record
yup so do you guys know which one you
are i'm a morning for sure i wish i was
morning you
you are morning and then you go to sleep
people for some reason
left me hanging like anthony davis i
feel all dancers are night people for
some reason because all the performances
are usually at night
there are a lot of people like that but
i i guess the reason why i'm talking
is more of my ability to think
creatively
i feel like i i have a almost like a
finite amount of creative like juice in
a day
me too i have to reset it it's like if i
run out of that juice
there's a possibility i can like go for
like a second session and have like a
second win
but usually i got to go to sleep wake up
the next day and then i have my energy
or my juice just kind of like
renewed and then from there i can be
creative in the morning again
when you say that um do you is it like
not having inspiration or your mind's
not firing because for me it's the mind
firing part
it's just like like things are just like
going and you're just thinking of
certain things so you just see and
believe and understand certain things
later on i can be inspired but it might
not necessarily like
turn into creative movement or like
energy
might be like inspired to just enjoy
something like like for me like with the
whole inspiration thing like
if i am trying to do something um like
let's say at night
from i don't know five to like eight i
can still
do what i've been trained to do but i'm
not inventing new [ __ ]
if i want to come out with something
creative innovative something that i
like
above what my skill level is at whatever
i'm doing it needs to be in the morning
then
that's when i'm innovating i'm like oh
[ __ ] this is some new creative [ __ ] but
but at night i can still do
and just be a good place holder for
myself yeah i think my um
physical biology fails me before
my ability to create so like i think
i'm constantly in a creative kind of
stage
whether it's like my hobbies or just the
way i think about
society or anything right but then i
noticed that
like for example let's say i want to
edit a video the desire is there
but my eyes are failing me or like my
brain
is telling me you need sleep but i have
the it wants to keep doing it and then i
think that
is what i face a lot like when you want
to have sex be already jacked off five
times yeah
exactly that's exactly what it feels
like yeah like
don't touch me there's nothing
absolutely nothing
my fitness or health or anything like i
want to keep doing more
and then um or like my body's not ready
for it
why are you laughing i don't know it's
just so relatable
jacking off five times and they're like
girls don't know how to relate they just
keep going
and they touch you like
it doesn't work anymore i'm just kidding
it's a sleep valve yeah
it's out yeah damn that's crazy
the relatability or just like
how unusable your dick is well because
everyone's a creative here
right right but how we harness this
energy and how we let it out
it is different and i think that for me
it's constantly
out but it's not always used in a way
that is um progressing something that is
like
business or something well i think the
key to like something that like bart was
talking about was uh
the ability to like for example even
stay creative or like do what you got to
do
but then to have like that innovative
moment i feel like that's kind of like
that zen flow when we're even talking
about the peak of creativity in general
that's like where maybe my high cortisol
like
feeling is because i have a spike in an
ability to do something that transcends
my normalcy in the day
and then for the rest of the day i'm
kind of like normal but like to find
like that
highest peak that's in the morning even
though i'm still like creative during
the day
but like the [ __ ] peak is what i'm
always looking for is it maybe clarity
is that word
right like i do have spurts of
everything's connecting
where there are times where like it's
not
because you're too uh cerebral or you're
like thinking about other [ __ ]
yeah yeah so like if when everything's
clear and you are in the zone
then that is the the peak of creativity
and then so you get it in the morning
well some people get it at night
yeah um that's exactly what i'm saying
do you try to schedule like all your
rehort rehearsals or whatever like the
motivation rehearsals i put in the
morning
do you create better alone or with
people it depends but i i like
in today's time frame i like creating
more with people because it's more
efficient for me
like if i have like people just
assisting me like you guys do the choreo
i'ma go
watch spongebob squarepants and then you
take all the credit
oh [ __ ] it's done like i'm a genius yeah
[ __ ] a spike dude spike that nightmare
i'm good at this [ __ ] dude i'm good at
this choreography oh
[ __ ] it's true though
nick for you for you like when it comes
to your your trade of like
sparring and then when you're thinking
about choking somebody out right
this way or this way at 3 pm i will [ __ ]
you up
for me because i as i'm hearing
everybody's i'm like man for me it's
really dependent on how my day is going
like it's
like how was my sleep the night before
am i doing a lot of physical activity in
the morning
if i'm doing a lot of physical activity
in the morning and it's pretty intense
by the night time i'm usually not as
like
i'm like pretty much fried but usually i
tend to feel more creative and more
productive at night
but it really depends on how my overall
schedule or like my weekly schedule is
you know like
i usually try to do most of my work in
the morning but
it really it really all depends and
that's why i'm like
man is something wrong with me like [ __ ]
i don't have i don't have
you're like ambidextrous with your
energies i guess maybe
but at the same time it really it's
really dependent on like the overall
schedule
because obviously when you're working
with clients or you're talking with
clients sometimes
some people take a lot more like mental
energy and
yeah yeah away from it or or just like
the type of training that you
do kind of takes a lot away what about
the times that you impress yourself
like for me regardless of the craft
right it's just it's just the times that
i impress myself
are always in the mornings whether i'm
working on like a jk thing or even like
if i'm coaching someone in a squat
like i'm like oh [ __ ] i couldn't believe
i don't believe that i just explained my
explain that in that way if i coached
someone that night i would never have
been able to explain to that when you
put it that way
probably the mornings probably the
mornings but i i feel like i've had a
lot of like
as far as like um what i'm trying to
outline like my training stuff or
whatever it usually happens at night
like i do really well at night but when
i'm trying to like write things out
or trying to communicate with a client
or something like that usually the
mornings
like mid-afternoons is probably the best
for me but i feel like on both ends i
so morning mid-afternoon night you're
just perfect
just terrible just awful but it's it's a
give or take right if i'm more
productive
at night the daytime i'm like i'm fried
or something like that or i'm not doing
anything or vice versa you know so
it really depends i wish i had a
consistent thing like you guys like in
the morning every single time
yeah it's so hit or miss man me too i
don't i wouldn't say i'm not a morning
person anymore because i just wake up
naturally in the morning now
but then um it's very hit or miss where
my peak
is like sometimes the mornings will be
great and sometimes
it won't you know yeah for me it depends
on what what i'm doing in that day and
what the activity is and then that's
when i
really feel like the creative juices or
the peak or whatever it is like it
depends on the activity
and but usually though that that
particular activity that gets me excited
if it's like butt ass early in the
morning then
i probably won't get that energy spike
because i just am not a morning person
period but yeah for me it's like the
activity
is more important yeah if i'm aware of
the schedule if i know i have to go into
something like in the evening i'll like
dead myself out and like conserve my
energy and not let myself like
uh use my creative flow in my juices and
i'll just like try
it's like a battery yeah just try and do
nothing
sometimes i wish like when it when it
comes to like extra virgin introversion
sometimes i'm like
i'm way more extroverted in the morning
when i wake up i have a bigger
capacity to like and communicate and
like be
engaged with people but then by night
time i'm like huh so i'm like
why can't the club life be in the
morning too like why can't there be a
version of club life in the morning i
thought that too
anthony me no i'm an extrovert who
really loves being a homebody yeah that
makes no sense that's who i am that's
how i feel i am
casey how dare you mean
amber amber what does that mean oh i
recently read something
it's called um highly sensitive person
but an extrovert you should look into
that what is that
that's someone who has who's an
extrovert but then like you get
overwhelmed with
so you always question am i an introvert
or extrovert maybe i'm an ambiver but
then like it's like you're super uh
sensitive and overwhelmed by these
interactions
because people's feelings are whatever
are heightened to you so it's exhausting
but you actually enjoy being an
extrovert and doing all these things
that's a new thing i found out so
there's an introverted version of that
which is
what my mom is uh what do you call it
it's hsp
highly sensitive person yeah that's me
dude
i'm gonna take that for some reason it
makes me not feel so hype i'm like i'm
super sensitive
[Laughter]
[Music]
you